his body as part of his job there's some
reason this is like the hardest and
challenges I've done hey guys my name is
Spencer Althouse and I do a lot of
fitness content for BuzzFeed lately I've
been thinking a lot about the way men
are portrayed in the media and as
someone who has always struggled with
body image issues and not feeling worthy
enough I sort of got into the subject of
modeling and it's such a foreign concept
to me so I wanted to explore that more
so I got in contact with nyle dimarco
he's probably one of the most famous
male models right now you probably know
him from America's Next Top Model he won
that Dancing with the Stars he won that
he's great he's very attractive and he's
very nice and he just happens to be deaf
so I reached out to him and I found out
what his workouts are and what his meal
plans are he works out four days a week
which is a little different from my
normal fitness challenges for BuzzFeed
normally I'm doing 30-day challenges and
every single day is the same sort of
workout so this challenge is super
interesting because I'm following one
specific person's journey and I get a
few rest days in between so yeah for the
next 30 days I'm gonna be living and
training like a famous model but half of
this project takes place in the gym and
the other half takes place in the
kitchen so I'm going grocery shopping
right now because I'm gonna meal prep
some of my meals for this week just
because there's a lot easier nyle says e
meal prep so if he does it I'm gonna do
it to stay one of the challenge it is 6
a.m. and I do not want to be up right
now perhaps eat started now it was a
pretty big breakfast she does 6 X 3 of
them whole and 3 whites and E has either
two slices of bread or a cup of oatmeal
with some honey so I decided to split
that up because they do my morning
workouts so I'll do half of that before
my workout with a protein shake yeah
they're half all do after the protein
- so you have to go make breakfast and
get ready for the drill there are a
couple reasons why I wanted to do this
challenge these challenges are a really
great way to hold myself accountable by
doing a 30-day challenge I know I'm
gonna really push myself for those 30
days but really nyle is deaf and a lot
of people don't know this about me but
when I was younger I had a really bad
block stutter and that basically means
when I try and speak I know exactly what
I want to say but the words physically
can't come out of my mouth I'm not super
honest about it with a lot of people a
lot of people who I work with they
probably don't know that I have this
block stutter and it used to be very bad
and like doing a video like this is hard
because sometimes it happens to me so
after talking to the trainer I feel so
bad that he's gonna have to edit this
but I only request is in the video can
you make it so I don't have a stutter at
all that would be a fantastic a lot of
the times and I fumble with it and I
pretend that I forget what I'm saying so
people don't catch on that I don't know
I used to go to a speech therapist all
the time I used to not speak at all
because I was so frightened by it but
working with nyle and wanting to do this
project with him it was kind of like
inspiring and humbling because he is
someone who is deaf and it's like really
powerful and cool to see what nyle is
done with his voice it is day one and a
month
Jim right now finished my first
breakfast a little nervous because day
one for now is a lot of shoulder
exercises he does a lot of shoulder
presses and bench presses and a lot of
his workouts are things that I haven't
done in a long time and that's mainly
because when I was a kid I broke my
shoulder and it's prevented me from
doing certain exercises so I always did
workarounds just still get the same
effect while working out but I just did
different exercises so I didn't hurt it
or straighten it but for this project I
had to follow exactly what Niall does
and I didn't want to change anything up
too much because I want you to see what
the results could be for yourself so I'm
a little nervous about that hopefully I
don't hurt myself but we'll see how it
goes the first workout was a lot of
bench presses and I honestly haven't
been pressed in I probably did it once
15 years ago and I didn't like it so I
just never did it and also it irritated
my shoulder so it was like really
humbling and kind of humiliating
experience to get back into all these
workouts humiliating in a good way
though because it's like I am doing all
of these things that I haven't done in a
very long time so I'm starting off at
such low weights especially compared to
what I'm used to going into this I knew
I had to set different limits for myself
because I was going to be starting from
day 1 of a fitness journey rather than
three years where I have been but I
finished the whole workout so we said it
about that it took me a lot longer than
normal so now I have to go make my
second breakfast of the day and my
overall earlier this morning when I woke
up and had a protein shake I went to the
gym another protein shake and I just
made the 6 eggs never eaten 6 eggs
before it seems pretty excessive but
there goes
finish my workouts finished eating most
of my meals something that is really
good for me right now because I'm so
tired I mule prepped all my meals last
night so all I have to do is stick it in
the microwave which is very good because
right now I just want to sleep but day
one pretty exhausted very tiring workout
now his workouts are like twice as hard
as mine even though he only does four
workouts a week he packs so much into
those workouts
he has like eight or nine exercises for
each day and I'm used to maybe doing
like four exercises for four a day
so I knew that it was gonna take me a
little longer I didn't know was gonna
take me as long as it did hey everyone
it is day 4 feel a lot more rested
thanks to yesterday but today is extra
exciting because in a little bit I'm
gonna be working out with nyle
so today Spencer and I had a chance to
go through my entire workout program we
went through each individual exercise I
had a chance to monitor his technique
and make sure that he had proper form so
this is the same idea right you want to
make sure that you're keeping that
curvature that arc to the time when
you're lifting
you can really feel the finger back
right
nice yeah so so far it's going pretty
well now so showing me proper form and
everything like that so I don't mess up
too much during the month so I'm
actually pretty excited with how it's
going I was super nervous to begin with
but I think it's off to a good start
I was happy to see he was practicing
perfect for him as that is the way to
get better result today honestly Spencer
impressed me his form was perfect his
technique was great and I think he's
ready to take on the program it was
incredible I was absolutely terrified
that I was gonna embarrass myself and
waste his time luckily that was not the
case he seemed super impressed and proud
of me it also really helped because I
told him about my shoulder injury when I
was a kid and so we worked together to
figure out alternative exercises to do
do you feel it you're feeling nothing on
your shoulder right feels good yeah that
way I wasn't gonna hurt my shoulder
anymore in the challenge and I can
complete the whole thing and see the
best results possible okay yeah tell me
what to do with that okay ready - laughs
okay so it's cross yeah hey guys
day seven finished at the gym not
feeling too good I don't know I had to
run today and I hate running I don't
know how to run it's not feeling good
about the challenge I keep comparing
myself to Nile which is so stupid
because I'm not a model so I had a lot
of ups and downs throughout this
challenge and a lot of it honestly
results in my body image issues I don't
always like the way that I see myself in
the mirror some days during this
challenge I will see results or I will
look in the mirror like oh my god this
is really paying off like I can see that
I'm getting stronger and feeling
stronger day 16 of the challenge feeling
pretty good I just looked in the mirror
and to be honest I saw a pretty big
change
I definitely feel and look a little
bigger than before which is really cool
I don't know to look at the mirror and
start to like what you see something
I've always struggled with and other
times I'm just not liking anything that
I see and it is terrible to feel that
way but the goal throughout this
challenge
I just realized like this is a thirty
day challenge and thirty days is not a
long time to see great results at the
gym and comparing yourself to other
people is like ridicu
because we're all at different stages
and the fitness journey and I'm doing
all these workouts that I've never
really done before or haven't done in a
long time so I'm starting off really
slow and it's just like so detrimental
to compare myself to someone who's in
like year 15 of his fitness journey
where I'm literally just starting his so
I'm getting pretty upset with myself and
I shouldn't be I'm kind of torn because
I'm on one side it's like I have to
question why I'm feeling so good it's
like oh because I'm getting stronger
and looking stronger and that means I'm
falling into the whole like media trap
of how a man is supposed to look so I
keep second-guessing everything and I
need to figure out why I'm happy I
understand my privilege in that I was
sort of fit to begin with and I can
afford a gym membership and my body is
able but I worked very hard to get to
the point in my life where I'm at right
now I've been doing this fitness thing
for several years and hopefully other
people will see this and either be
inspired or want to follow niles journey
as well I am a huge believer in everyone
is starting their journey at different
times no one is looking for the same
thing as someone else so do whatever
you're comfortable with and whatever you
want to do don't do it for some other
reason so the goal is not a models
physique this is about feeling more
comfortable in my body this is about
feeling more confident at the gym this
is about liking myself more and if it
takes acting like someone for 30 days
and like following their workouts and
their meal plans to start to better
myself then I think that's a great thing
and hopefully through my progress you'll
think maybe this is something I can do
everyone it is day 20 that means I am
two-thirds done the project very happy
about that projects actually been going
super well it's been flying by I think a
big reason why it's been going so fast
is because I've been dividing it into
weekly increments thinking about like a
year-long challenge or a 30-day
challenge is kind of daunting because it
seems like a lot of time and especially
with Niles where he works out four days
a week you really only have to devote
four days to it and then after you do it
for the four days you're gonna think
that was so easy why shouldn't I do this
for longer and then you will day 22 I'm
trying to really push myself these last
few days just because I want to see the
best results possible because it'd be a
shame if I do this whole thing and I
only half-ass it but I'm putting in the
work and you can see because the
calluses on my hands are getting pretty
big it is day 29 of the challenge
literally almost done I think this is
probably the most practical challenge
that I've done so far for BuzzFeed and
that like anyone can pretty much do it
the other ones are kind of limiting but
this challenge training like a famous
model or a training like Niall is just
more doable in that most of the
exercises can they're all found in like
a normal gym anywhere in the country so
it's not like if you need a specialty
boutique gym or anything like that you
can do this wherever you are all right
I'm going for my second-to-last work out
of the challenge it is day 30 of the
challenge yeah final day I'm on my way
to the gym right now I'm gonna push
myself as hard as I can if you're
watching this video and you're skipping
right to the before-and-after pictures
you might see a transformation and if
you do great if not I'm sure you'll tell
me in the comments below so yeah and the
before pictures you can definitely tell
even though there's like parts of ABS
there you can see I'm bloated and I was
like always bloated I guess the
following nails diet and workouts I
don't know I'm not as bloated anymore in
it havin to I feel like more comfortable
in my body just all around I can see my
chest has definitely gotten bigger but
really there are so many other elements
to this there are so many other
transformations that aren't just about
the weight that I gained or lost or the
muscle that I gained
so whether you want to look like a
famous model or you just want to lose a
couple of pounds or you just want to get
up from your couch and start walking
more it sounds so cheesy but it really
is just basic it's about watching what
you eat and it's about exercising and
these are things that all of us can do
and I don't mean to sound like a
personal trainer because I'm not a
personal trainer I am a regular person
just like you I have a full-time job I
try and have a personal life so if I can
do this if I can get up early or stay
late or do the meal prepping and all of
that stuff I promise it is worth it it's
doable and if I can do it you can
definitely do it to everyone thank you
so much for watching the video if you
want to read about my BuzzFeed fitness
article or if you want to find out more
about now's workout plans there's meal
plans just click the link in the
description below it's all there
you
[Music]